besonderen gast er hat mit der tradition
seiner vorgängerin gebrochen zu den
fragen der festspiele nach bayreuth zu
fahren aber er hat nicht mit der
tradition gebrochen vor oder nach dem
sommerurlaub in die
bundespressekonferenz zur traditionellen
sommerpressekonferenz
kommen ich begrüße ganz herzlich
bundeskanzler und herzlich willkommen
platz genommen gegeben sprecher steffen
hebestreit auch wenn sie ein herzliches
willkommen oder scholz ist dass hansa
das erste mal drei uns aber er ist
natürlich nicht das erste mal in der
bundespressekonferenz unser büro hat man
nachgezählt sie waren schon 33 mal bei
uns etwa 23 mal als finanzminister
sechsmal als arbeits und sozialminister
einmal als generalsekretär wird zwar
zweimal als kommissarischer spd-chef und
einmal als hamburger bürgermeister
bevor sie mit dem kurzen
eingangsstatement beginnen und wir zu
den fragen kommen möchte ich für alle
die diese pressekonferenz live sehen und
im stream und nicht wissen dass die
bundespressekonferenz ist noch kurz
erklären was wir sind die
bundespressekonferenz ist ein
unabhängiger verein von journalistinnen
und journalisten die aus berlin über die
bundespolitik richten unsere aufgabe ist
es pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten und
diese pressekonferenzen dienen und jetzt
zitiere ich mal aus unserer satzung
einer sachlichen an tatsachen
orientierten und fairen vermittlung von
politischen informationen aussagen und
position hängen
und damit herr scholz haben sie das wort
bitteschön schon
dank schönen dank für die einladung
zu dieser
bundespressekonferenz und die
gelegenheit ein bisschen über alle
themen die sie bewegen zu sprechen und
die natürlich auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes umtreiben wir
haben ernste zeiten das glaube ich weiß
jeder und jede in diesem land ernst zu
zeiten die uns auch noch viel
abverlangen werden was diesen winter und
das nächste jahr betrifft aber es ist
auch so dass wir jetzt um diesen sommer
ein bisschen spüren dass es den urlaub
gibt dass man ein bisschen das schöne
wetter und die zeit genießen kann und
ich habe den eindruck dass viele bürger
haben das auch tun ich habe mich in
meinem urlaub geholt ich hoffe sie haben
das in ihrem auch oder steht noch bevor
im übrigen ist es so dass wir viele
themen haben die wir gleich diskutieren
sondern ein paar gewiss ansprechen die
größte herausforderung ist natürlich der
politik die in russland gegen die
ukraine begonnen hat und der jetzt schon
so viele monate währt und unverändert
verlangt dass wir weit reichende
entscheidungen treffen um die ukraine in
ihrem kampf von rom abhängigkeit zu
unterstützen wir tun das wie sie wissen
durch einen massiven bruch mit
bisheriger praxis und dem gewachsenen
liefern sehr viele sehr weitreichend wie
effiziente und das werden wir auch die
nächste zeit weiter tun wir unterstützen
die ukraine finanziell und wir haben uns
darauf eingestellt dass das was mit
diesem krieg verbunden ist die ganze
welt gerührt aber selbstverständlich
auch europa und unser land da geht es
insbesondere um preisentwicklung aber
auch um die versorgung und die
herausforderung die damit verbunden sind
deshalb ist es so
dass wir uns genau auf diese situation
intensiv vorbereitet haben ich habe
bereits im dezember des letzten jahres
kommen dass sich kanzler geworden war
und wirtschaftsministerium gefragt was
passiert eigentlich wenn es plötzlich
kein gas mehr geliefert wird das auch im
kanzleramt recherchieren lassen und
meine feststellung zu der zeit war diese
frage hat sich nun offenbar bis dahin
niemand so richtig gestellt und sie auch
niemand zu ende die antwort deshalb war
es wichtig dass wir noch vor
kriegsbeginn angefangen haben dafür zu
sorgen dass wir uns auf diese situation
vorbereiten und wir haben seither viele
entscheidungen getroffen die aus dieser
vorbereitung stand schnell flüssiggas
terminals an den norddeutschen küsten zu
bauen gesetze zu ändern dass das auch
wirklich schnell geht die entsprechenden
technischen infrastrukturen zu
beschaffen insbesondere klassifizierungs
anlagen betrifft wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass wir die speicher voll kriegen in
dem gesetze gemacht haben die genau das
regeln anders als im letzten jahr so
dass die jetzt erwarten dürfen dass sie
viel voller die in ihr zeugt von viel
voller als im letzten jahr und so werden
auch gefüllt werden wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass kraftwerke kohle
kraftwerken wieder in betrieb genommen
werden können die ersten des bereits mit
den übrigen betreibern sind wir nach den
gesetzlichen veränderungen bewirkt haben
jetzt im gespräch und wir prüfen ob es
sinn macht und erforderlich ist die drei
vorhandenen atomkraftwerke noch etwas
länger laufen zu lassen das wird bald
festgestellt werden können wenn die
infranor untersuchungen abgeschlossen
sind also eine intensive vorbereitung
auf die situation wir uns jetzt
bevorsteht genauso wie die entscheidung
die wir getroffen haben um dann die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten das
ist schon das zweite entlastungspaket
von unserem 30 milliarden euro ist noch
nicht vollständig umgesetzt viele der
ausgang sind bleibt diskutiert worden
ein euro ticket die
fristen der ersparnis an den tankstellen
der steuerverzicht aber
selbstverständlich auch die vielen
anderen leistungen die zum beispiel mit
einer anhebung des grundfreibetrags der
arbeitnehmerpauschale der
pendlerpauschale verbunden sind mit
direktzahlungen an familien mit 100 euro
für jedes kind 20 euro für arme kinder
monatlich mit 200 euro für
grundsicherungsempfänger an der
heizkosten verschalung die wir auf den
weg gebracht haben und natürlich der
umfassenden abschaffung der eeg-umlage
seit mitte diesen jahres das dem
strompreis von einer steuerlichen
belastung von etwa 20 milliarden euro
befreit hat die bisher dort jedes jahr
an gefallen ist das sind diese maßnahme
aber wir werden neben den notwendigen
energie sparen dass wir alle machen
damit durch diese zeit kommen und denen
entlastungsmaßnahmen liebe für die
bürgerin bürger bisher ergriffen haben
auch weitere greifen müssen und dazu ist
die regierung auf fest entschlossen ich
habe das zusammengefasst mit der
formulierung you'll never walk alone und
das will ich auch hier noch einmal
wiederholen wir werden alles dafür tun
dass die bürgerinnen bürger durch diese
schwierige zeit kommt mir geht es dabei
um diejenigen die ganz wenig haben und
deshalb haben wir gesagt geworden beim
wohngeld was machen dann bürgergeld und
sind dabei intensiv diese reformen
vorzubereiten wir haben gesagt wir
wollen das für diejenigen machen die ein
arbeitseinkommen haben aber auch rechnen
müssen die keine ersparnisse haben sie
mit dem plötzlichen
gestiegenen energiekosten zum beispiel
nicht ohne weiteres umgehen können und
für die höheren heizkosten das aus nach
das gilt für ganz ganz viele deutsche
bürger es gibt mehr um diejenigen die
258 diesen 3200 euro brutto im monat
5000 euro könnte das alles große
herausforderungen sind und deshalb ist
klar dass für den gesamt paket das wir
ergreifen werden sicherlich auch
steuerlichen entlastungsmaßnahmen dazu
gehören der finanzminister hat seinen
beitrag zu den notwendigen überlegungen
dazu gestern vorgestellt wurde das sehr
hilfreich häufiger ein gesamtpaket
schnüren müssen dass alle
bevölkerungsgruppen
umfasst diejenigen die breite
mehrheit der bevölkerung den geringe
oder normale einkommen hat rentnern
rentner studierende und das wird auch am
ende das gesamtpaket diese entwicklung
sein damit niemand alleine gelassen wird
niemand vor unlösbare probleme gestellt
wird und keiner die herausforderung mit
den gestiegenen preisen verbunden sind
alleine schultern muss
zwei letzte kurzen beladung wird all den
entscheidungen die die jetzt wegen des
krieges zu treffen haben ist nicht
verbunden dass wir unsere übrigen
vorhaben aufgeben sie wissen dass erst
nach über die anhebung des mindestlohns
auf 12 euro geben wird sie wissen dass
wir
bereits auf den weg gebracht haben dass
erwerbsminderungsrente mehr geld
bekommen dass es gesetzlich geschlossen
wir werden die rente stabilisieren wir
werden den wohnungsbau voran bringen wir
haben massiv zusätzliche mittel für
sozialen wohnungsbau bereitgestellt all
diese dinge kommen die wir uns
vorgenommen haben das gilt auch für die
zukunft weiter wichtig sein denn das ist
auch einer der größen eine der großen
herausforderung die wir haben und die
andere schlussbemerkung
die industrielle modernisierung die
wohlstandssicherung dort aus die
sicherstellung unserer unabhängigkeit
und autonomie
das ist das zentrale gemeinsame reformen
vorabend dieser regierung und deshalb
haben wir schon eine ganze reihe von
gesetzespaket auf den weg gebracht mit
dem wir den schnellen ausbau der
windkraft in deutschland an land und auf
hoher see solarenergie der stromnetze
rechtlich absichern und gesetz nicht auf
dem weg bringen und vorschreiben wir
werden dieses tempo fortsetzen das gilt
auch für den umbau der industrie ob das
nun die automobilindustrie ist die stahl
und regen stehen das training beenden
industries die eine andere grundlagen
brauchen für ihre art und weise der
produktion um die das tun wollen und
dass wir ihnen dazu versprechen müssen
ist ein gutes umfeld in großer menge
bezahlbare energie insbesondere strom
und wasserstoff aus erneuerbaren quellen
und genau das tun wir wir arbeiten
sämtliche versäumnisse der letzten jahre
ab die in dieser hinsicht wirklich groß
waren weil es tragen die gemeinsame
entscheidung gab über ausstieg aus kohle
verstromung atomenergie aber keinen
entscheidungen die ein großes tempo für
diese industrielle modernisierung
deutschlands mit sich gebracht hätten
mit leder windmühle mit jeder
solaranlage mit jeder neu in betrieb
genommenen stromtrasse sinkt die
abhängigkeit deutschlands von fossilen
ressourcen die aus aller welt
importieren müssen das ist die gute
botschaft mit jeder dieser anlagen wird
die perspektive der energieversorgung
auch billiger weil wir dann diese
ressourcen zurückgreifen können und mit
ihr der anlage steigt die chance für den
industriellen umbau den wir uns
vorgenommen haben und
gleichzeitig tun wir das was notwendig
ist um das klima zu schützen die andere
große aufgabe gegangen und in dem sinne
freue ich mich sehr auf unsere gespräche
auf den fragen und geben gern meine
antworten dann kommen sie zu fragen da
hier gerade gesagt mindestens 80 händler
gleichzeitig hoch zugangs und arbeitet
und spaziert durch diese frage liste
durch ich erinnere noch mal unsere regel
eine frage eine zusatzfrage wir haben
inzwischen 75 minuten und 90 minuten
zeit und da wir die masten pflicht
geklagt und sei heute ausnahmsweise noch
einmal erlassen abend wegen der fülle
des salz und die masken auch in frage
stellen auch bleiben sollten macht es
wahrscheinlich sehen dass sich alle noch
mal vorstellen wenn man nicht immer alle
erkennt dann hat die erste frage frau
münch
die bürger bürger können sich darauf
verlassen dass wir sie nicht lange wir
haben das hier gezeigt mit den beiden
leistungspaketen von zusammen 30
milliarden euro die wir schon auf dem
licht gebracht haben und die ich eben
noch diskutiert habe eine der maßnahmen
diese energiepreis prämie die ist ja
noch gar nicht wirksam das wird im
september passieren und wenn man dann
ende september auf seine lohnabrechnung
gucken wir dass das erste mal
realisieren also dann sieht man das
passiert alles aber wir haben das zu
einem zeitpunkt entschieden als noch
niemand das wird nicht als großes thema
diskutiert da sind noch viele andere
fragen diskutiert die auch wichtig und
bedeutsam sind unter schwierigen zeit an
dem wir uns gegenwärtig befinden aber
die frage zu entlasten wir die
bürgerinnen bürger gerade noch nicht das
top thema der agenda und schon hatten
wir zwei pakete auf den weg gebracht und
deshalb ist die klare antwort auf ihre
frage es wird auch ein weiteres paket
geben dass wir als bundesregierung
schnüren und mit dem wir den bürgern und
bürgern helfen werden dass sie die
herausforderung mit gestiegenen preisen
verbunden sind auch bewältigen können
unsere wirtschaftslage ist ja
gegenwärtig trotz dieser schwierigkeiten
davon gekennzeichnet dass wir eine hohe
beschäftigung haben und sie sogar weiter
steigt und deshalb glaube ich haben wir
alle chancen und durch diese zeit zu
kommen auch wenn es schwierig wird denn
das ist ja etwas was niemand
wichtigen teil schreiben darf wir müssen
sicherstellen dass alle wissen doch es
gibt eine herausforderung der
energieversorgung weil wir uns eben
nicht auf die sätze der letzten
jahrzehnte verlassen können die immer
geheißen haben egal was los ist russland
wird gas liefern die antwort ist es gibt
keine gast sanktionen aus europa und
trotzdem würden die lieferung reduziert
und das ist ja ein sicheres zeichen
dass wir das richtige getan haben als
wir schon ende letzten jahres begonnen
haben uns mit der frage zu beschäftigen
was passiert eigentlich wenn entgegen
aller vorhersagen ob es doch passiert
sie sehen wir an dem einen ersten das
noch kippen die wir auf den weg gebracht
haben dass manche maßnahmen dass es im
frühjahr entschieden werden jetzt erst
dann auch war das nicht von antrag den
anderen weg wichtig ist deshalb dass die
entscheidung treffen damit alle sich
darauf verlassen können und wenn sie
rechnen bekommen sie durch dieses und
das nächste jahr das tun ja ganz viele
bürgerinnen und bürger das auch genau im
blick haben ich habe mit vielen
gesprochen auch bei sparkassen banken
und anderen viele rückmeldungen bekommen
und manchmal sagen wert als eine
bürgerin bürger die haben keine
ersparnisse die kommen mit ihrem
arbeitseinkommen so gerade zurecht und
wenn die jetzt hören dass sie vielleicht
ein paar hundert euro mehr für die als
rechnung zahlen müssen und ihr versorger
in das bett teilt dann in der lässt das
ein mulmiges gefühl
und deshalb ist die ganz klare aussage
damit dann geht ihm bürgern und bürger
nicht alleine lassen
wir wollten
[Musik]
das thema kreuz steht in deutschland zu
bewerkstelligen stück unverändert als
große aufgabe für uns an und das
eigentlich die drei koalitionsparteien
auch während unterschiedliche parteien
und haben nicht durch den
koalitionsvertrag uns zu einem
vereinigungsparteitag versammelt sondern
zu einer gemeinsamen regierung
vereinbart und das werden wir auch
hinkriegen weiter machen und dabei gute
lösung für unser land finden und gerade
in den fragen die wichtig sind dass
liberalität betrifft was die frage
betrifft die kriegen werden die
arbeitskräftebedarf unser zukunft
gewährleistet auch durch eine kluge
politik platz acht plätze anderen
gedrückt wie kriegen wir das hin dass
wir die technologische modernisierung
deutschlands zustande bringen so dass
das tatsächlich möglich ist dass wir
auch in zehn 20 30 jahren noch ein
führendes industrieland sind mit
weltweit export fähigen technologien das
alles wird diese koalition weiter
intensiv vorantreiben und darüber haben
wir uns klar verabredet es ist sogar so
dass wegen der von ihnen angesprochenen
veränderung wir noch mehr tempo in die
sache bringen denn dass wir unabhängig
werden müssen von dem import von kohle
öl und gas das ist glaube ich für alle
jetzt ganz ganz klar und deshalb werden
wir die kraft haben für das tempo das
wir bei der industriellen und
wirtschaftlichen modernisierung unserer
energieversorgung und unserer produktion
brauchen was die zeitenwende betrifft
die mit russlands angriffskrieg
verbunden ist mache ich mir da nichts
vor ich habe sie bewusst so genannt das
ist eine veränderung der wirklichkeit in
der wir leben denn russland hat gesagt
es denkt weiter und erneut in den
kategorien des 17 18 19 jahrhunderts in
realistischer machtpolitik und hält es
für möglich mit gewalt einen nachbarn
anzugreifen und sich ein teil seines
territoriums unter den nagel zu reißen
das können wir nicht ändern indem wir da
nur zuschauen sondern nur indem wir das
tun was jetzt unsere sache ist und das
ist eben die unterstützung der ukraine
aber das heißt eben auch für unsere
eigene sicherheit mehr zu tun ich habe
vorgeschlagen dass wir 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
auf den weg bringen dass wir sie besser
ausstatten und dass wir mehr geld für
verteidigung ausgäben dauerhaft weil wir
nur mit einer starken eigenen
verteidigung sicherstellen können dass
uns und die nato-mitgliedstaaten niemand
angreifen das ist die konsequenz der
zeitenwende und dass wir das schnell
entschieden haben dass es auch ein gutes
zeichen für diese koalition dass es uns
gelungen ist dafür zweidrittelmehrheiten
in bundestag und bundesrat zu bekommen
ist ein gutes zeichen für unser land
die nächste frage von dunst
das sind alles vom redaktions netzwerk
in deutschland herr bundeskanzler müsste
mit einer nachfrage zur ersten frage
anfangen weil sie die nicht ganz
beantwortet hatten zu den sozialen
spannungen sie haben nur gesagt was die
regierung machen wird deswegen zuerst
die nachfrage bitte ob sie glauben dass
das was sie angekündigt haben zur
beruhigung führt oder ob es nicht doch
zu unruhe im land kommen kann wenn sich
die situation verschärft nein ich glaube
nicht dass es in diesem land zu unruhen
in dieser skizzierte form kommen wird
und zwar deshalb weil deutschland ein
sozialstaat ist helmut schmidt hat das
mal eine der größten erfindungen der
deutschen politik empfunden und
beschrieben und dieser sozialstaat muss
in dieser situation wirksam sein in dem
klar sagt dass wir niemanden alleine
lassen werden ich habe das bewusst mit
diesem begriff du wirst nicht alleine
durch die zukunft gehen gesagt you never
walk alone und das gilt das ist das was
unsere antwort darauf ist und deshalb
bin ich ganz zuversichtlich die bürgern
und bürger sind schlau machen sich
nichts vor sie wissen dass das jetzt
nicht ganz einfach wird und das ist
nicht alle probleme der form zu kommen
unsere hand liegen denn es entscheidet
ja jemand anders und anderswo jemand
über die frage wie das mit der
energieversorgung unseres landes ist ob
verträge eingehalten werden oder nicht
aber wir bereiten uns vor in der sache
und wir helfen den bürgern bürgern und
den unternehmen dass sie diese
schwierige situation bewältigen kann und
weil diese botschaft klar ist bin ich
ganz sicher dass wir uns unterhalten und
das dass die deutsche antwort auf eine
solche herausforderung sein wird dann
wäre ich bei der eigentlichen frage
nämlich nach der schuldenbremse diese
single never walk alone bedeutet ja egal
was es kostet wird die schuldenbremse
weiter ausgesetzt bleiben und muss es
für weitere entlastungen nicht noch in
diesem jahr dann einen nachtragshaushalt
geben wir gehen davon aus dass wir
unsere vorstellungen mit den
finanziellen in dem finanziellen rahmen
bewältigen können der uns bisher zur
verfügung steht wir müssen natürlich
ausgehend von entwicklungen die wir
vorhersagen und prognostizieren können
jede veränderung bedeutet immer dass
nochmals inspizieren aber ich habe sehr
unterstützt dass wir ein
haushaltsentwurf als bundesregierung
vorliegen der für 2023 sich an die
regeln des grundgesetzes hält sowieso
aber eben auch nicht von den ausnahme
möglichkeiten gebrauch gemacht jetzt
sollten wir uns darauf konzentrieren die
konkreten vorschläge zu entwickeln und
ich bin sicher dass wir sie finanzieren
können
ich wechsele einmal nach links herr
herr bundeskanzler ich würde ganz so
glas versorgung nachfragen wollen
im hafen von brunsbüttel wird seit zwölf
jahren an einem terminal herum geplant
sind sie wirklich sicher dass in
wilhelmshaven brunsbüttel bis zum ende
des jahres schwimmende terminals in
betrieb gehen können und kommt das ganze
nicht zu spät und zu wenig an wasser um
noch nennenswert russisches gas ablösen
zu können
ja es wird schon sehr lange an diesen
dingen gearbeitet ich erinnere mich auch
als hamburger bürgermeister in einer
sitzung mit dem damaligen
ministerpräsident schleswig deutschlands
und dem damaligen umweltminister
schlüssel konzerns teilgenommen zu haben
indem wir die perspektiven bundes
viertels als allen sie
uns verständlich da
und ich habe in den jahren seither immer
intensiv dieses projekt um vorher auch
schon verfolgt sowohl für brunsbüttel
als auch für stade und wilhelmshaven und
mich auch immer wieder neue erkundigt
widerstand dieser projekte ist das ist
ein großer segen für uns weil wir als
wäre es entschieden haben diese
terminals zu bauen nicht bei null
anfangen mussten sondern da sind
jahrelange vorplanung gewesen auf die
man jetzt zurückgreifen konnte und die
nur nur nie wirtschaftlich was geworden
sind weil es immer niemanden gegeben hat
der flüssiggas durch diese termin ist in
großem umfang importieren wollte so dass
die investoren ihre
investitionsentscheidung immer
verschoben hat meine ansicht auch vor
einigen jahren war schon wir sollten das
dann möglicherweise mit öffentlichem
geld unterstützen so dass die anlagen da
sind und für den fall dass sie gebraucht
werden genutzt werden können dazu konnte
sich niemand durchringen das ist sogar
öffentlich kritisiert worden aber jetzt
haben wir eben diese basis und darum
wird es jetzt auch schnell gehen und die
antwort auf ihre frage ist ja die ersten
flüssiggas terminals werden am beginn
des nächsten jahres in diesem winter
angeschlossen wir sind damit
unglaublichem tempo unterwegs und wir
versuchen möglichst viele davon zu
etablieren wenn es geht so viel wie
möglich in betrieb zu nehmen auch im
laufe des nächsten jahres so dass wir in
eine situation kommen wo wir sagen
müssen
wegen der weltmarkt lage ist es
vielleicht etwas teurer gas zu
beschaffen aber wir werden immer genug
kriegen darum geht es ja und das glaube
ich wenn wir hinkriegen
zusatzfragen gibt es ja das elend
beschleunigungsgesetz das scheint auch
mal richtig zu wirken
die genehmigung für brunsbüttel
beispielsweise gibt noch ganz und die
genehmigung hände sind ja mehrere
das gesetz wirkt und ist auch eine gute
stütze warum sich jetzt alle so auf den
weg machen ich kann ihnen sagen dass wir
mit den betreibern der verschiedenen den
investoren der verschiedene projekte in
billings hafenstadion brunsbüttel
intensiv sprechen und ich könnte jetzt
sehr viele details sagen die aber
letztendlich in der übersetzung bedeuten
doch es wird mit riesigen tempo das
vorangetrieben und es wird auch noch an
vielen vielen einzelmaßnahmen gearbeitet
um das tempo weiter zu beschleunigen
die nächste frage hat frau lehmann
rena lehmann von der neuen osnabrücker
zeitung sie hatten eingangs schon gesagt
dass sie die vorschläge von christian
lindner gestern hilfreich fanden oder
erfreulich enden das wären ja in ihrer
partei nicht alle so und auch bei den
bei den grünen gibt es vorbehalte mit
dem inflationsausgleich gesetzt würden
vor allem besserverdienende im nächsten
jahr profitieren
haben sie auch kritik an dem vorschlag
oder stellen sie sich komplett dahinter
und wird dann sozusagen das teil eines
großen gesamt aus entlastungspaket was
da noch kommt im oktober
der bundesminister der finanzen olaf
scholz hat zweimal die kalte progression
ausgeglichen
vielmehr der gesetzgeber hat seinem
vorschlag folge geleistet was zu machen
das kann ja wenn ich das so sagen darf
kein offensichtlich falsche idee sein
sowas ab und zu zu machen und die
wir haben sogar in dieser
legislaturperiode auch mit steuerlichen
entlastung schon auf diese krise
reagiert indem wir den grundfreibetrag
angehoben haben das ja bedeutet das dass
nicht besteuerte existenz region
angehoben worden ist
wir haben die pendlerpauschale angehoben
und deshalb kann man ganz klar sagen zu
dem gesamtpaket das die regierung
vorbereiten wird gehört definitiv auch
dass es steuerliche entlastung gibt und
natürlich werden wir gemeinsam gucken
wie kriegen wir das hin dass diejenigen
auch
mit einem höheren nettoeinkommen durch
diese herausforderung auch
von höheren preisen kommen können indem
sie in dem wir das steuerlich möglich
machen das geht ja gar nicht anders und
insofern finde ich das einen guten
aufschlag für das was wir jetzt
diskussionen haben da sind ja auch viele
andere dinge schon öffentlich genannt
worden und wir werden das zusammenbinden
zu einem sehr effizienten paket ich
wiederhole noch mal wir können mit
bestimmten maßnahmen was jetzt rentner
betrifft das studierende betrifft was
diejenigen betrifft die so wenig
verdienen dass wir das was wir mit
wohngeld ihnen helfen müssen und dass
den berechtigten kreis ausweiten und
heizkosten dort nicht nur einmal wie in
der vergangenheit sondern dauerhaft
berücksichtigen wir können dabei
etwas tun aber natürlich geht es auch um
diejenigen die darüber liegen mit ihrem
einkommen knapp oder etwas mehr aber die
auf rechnern müsse jeden tag wie sie
zurechtkommen und das ist mir ein
persönliches anliegen
da werden wir eine gemeinsame vorschlag
entwickeln
kann sie noch eine größenordnung nennen
also dass herr lindner verkehrt wird jan
1 15 milliarden kosten
wir sollten
von der problemlage her
losmarschieren also gucken was müssen
wir machen damit diejenigen die arbeiten
aber nicht so gut verdienen dass sie die
teure einheitspreise und wohnungspreise
finanzieren können unterstützen das ist
die wohngeld frage wir sollten überlegen
was ist jetzt mit dem bürgergeld reform
das richtige wir sollten überlegen was
können wir tun im hinblick auf rentner
studenten was können wir tun für
diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und deshalb von den
steuerentlastungen nicht zu viel haben
und was können wir für die tun bei dem
die steuerbelastung genau das richtige
instrument ist dann rechnen wir das
zusammen und gucken ob uns das leisten
mein gefühl sagt geworden das können
dann die nächste folgerichtige
micro
dieser job wird virtual in die russische
reaktion
thema ukraine der amerikanische
präsident biden nennt oder die man putin
schlechter und kriegsverbrecher teilen
sie diese einschätzung soll aus ihrer
sicht wegen der wegen des überfalls auf
die ukraine zur tötung der zivilisten
zur rechenschaft der verantwortung
gezogen werden
das ist ein verbrecherischer krieg
darüber gibt es gar keine zweifel wir
haben auch viele kriegsverbrechen mit
großem entsetzen gesehen ich erinnere
mich noch an meinen besuch in der
ukraine
und natürlich werde ich nie vergessen
die bilder von den autos in den
familien saßen die aus der stadt fliehen
wollten die angehalten und erschossen
worden sind und das ist ja nur ein
beispiel für das ungeheuerliche was dort
in der ukraine von den russischen
soldaten
ausgehend geschieht und deshalb bin ich
sehr überzeugt davon dass wir auch alle
maßnahmen ergreifen müssen um alle diese
verbrechen aufzuklären das geschieht mit
unseren möglichkeiten der
bundesjustizminister ist da sehr aktiv
das geschieht mit den möglichkeiten die
wir bei der unterstützung
internationaler gerichtsbarkeit in
diesem fall haben und wir werden noch
als europäische union in dieser frage
zusammenarbeiten
also das wird alles aufgeklärt und
werden ob wir werden ein dingen die wir
ganz konkret ermitteln können nachgehen
und auch die ukrainischen würden dabei
unterstützen alle fälle aufzuklären und
sie auch mit der technik zu versehen
dass sie das kann
was ist wenn mit der persönlichen
verantwortung des russischen präsidenten
fragen ich meine der russische präsident
trägt die verantwortung für diesen klick
er hat entschieden dass es ihm geben
soll dann das ist ein furchtbarer
unakzeptabler krieg an krieg der gegen
alle regeln verstößt und der mit den
regeln bricht die wir miteinander
vereinbart haben ich wiederhole noch mal
was ich gesagt habe das ist eine
zeitenwende
weil die verständigung dass man nicht
sein nachbarn einfach über feld weil man
in irgend einem geschichtsbuch gelesen
hat einen teil seines territoriums
gehörte besser zum eigenen land das ist
die bedrohung von der wir jetzt alle
konfrontiert sind und die weisen wir
zurück und müssen wir auch zurückweisen
mit dem möglichkeiten die wir haben
dann habe ich als nächstes auf meiner
liste herrn steiner
ja vielen hatten dank patienten von
steinach war sondern dass die frage die
sich mir stellt wir haben jetzt 30
jahren halbe stunde gebraucht um das
thema europa auch nur ein einziges mal
anzusprechen
schauen sie dann auf die tatsächliche
solidarität derzeit in der europäischen
union zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
momentan sehen wir zum beispiel die
stromversorgung in frankreich die aus
deutschland mit gewährleistet wird
erhoffen sie sich denn dass die
solidarität in diesem winter auch in die
andere richtung tatsächlich
funktionieren wird
zum dank das ist hier ja die
bundespressekonferenz ich habe ein sehr
kurzes eingangsdaten gehalten bewusst
und ansonsten ist es ja an ihnen mit
ihren fragen die themen zu bestimmen
über die ich mich dann äußern und
deshalb freue ich mich sehr dass sie
jetzt eine frage zu europa gestellt die
solidarität in der europäischen union
ist doch besser als sie vor einigen
jahren vorhergesagt wurde ich glaube
dass man wenn man nur das tagesaktuelle
betrachtet da den blick schnell also den
überblick verliert wir noch mal ändern
die reaktion auf die korona pandemie da
gab es jetzt in der frage wie geht man
mit der konkreten pandemie bekämpfen wo
man am anfang wirklich einige
entscheidung die sehr kritisierbar waren
das grenzschließungen ähnliches betrifft
und dem versuch sich nur alleine zu
helfen aber im großen und ganzen ist es
doch gut gelungen und gerade was die
wirtschaftliche und soziale antwort
betrifft haben wir mit dem
wiederaufbau programm der europäischen
union dem european recovery program und
all den sachen die dazu gehören doch
gezeigt wir können zusammen halten und
das hat auch dazu beigetragen dass
europa durch diese krise jedenfalls
besser gekommen ist als alle das
vorhergesehen haben und dass all die
dinge die wir nach der großen dem
zusammenbruch von lehman brothers erlebt
hat und die dann als staatsschuldenkrise
uns alle umgetrieben haben bisher nicht
passiert und
wir haben auch sehr einheitlich und sehr
solidarisch auf die russische aggression
reagiert das darf man ja nicht vergessen
es sind sehr viele sehr weitreichende
veränderungen zustande gekommen es gibt
neue bewegungen in dem aufnahmeprozess
der sechs westlichen balkanstaaten die
2003 das versprechen bekommen hat nun
dass sie mitglied der europäischen union
werden können und nun im jahre 2023
befürchten dass das immer noch weit weg
ist das haben wir geändert und ich hoffe
dass das jetzt auch bei dem tempo bleibt
die dinge voranzutreiben wir haben
entscheidung getroffen mit
angeboten in hinblick auf die ukraine
und moldau wir haben entscheidungen
getroffen im hinblick auf der die
aktionspakete mehrere die wir
gemeinschaftlich zustande gebracht haben
wir haben entscheidungen getroffen die
der verbesserung unserer
energieversorgung dienen und dort auch
dafür sorgen dass wir europäische
infrastrukturen schaffen die den
wechselseitige unterstützung leichter
machen und deshalb bin ich auch sicher
werden wir wenn es jetzt klappt wird
weiter solidarisch bleiben deutschland
wird es jedenfalls sein
nachhaltig dazu es gab in den
vergangenen monaten regelmäßig kritik
insbesondere aus ich habe meine
polnischen kreisen an der rolle
deutschlands
derzeit in polen offenbar auch teilweise
zumindest mit an dem was an gas aus
deutschland mit dort rüber geliefert
werden kann nach den russischen aktionen
an der stelle wie zuversichtlich sind
sie dass in deutschland das verständnis
dafür überwiegen wird im winter wenn
deutschland seine knochen gasreserven
mit anderen europäischen staaten teilen
muss
bekenne mich ausdrücklich dazu dass wir
durch schwierige zeiten als europäischen
union solidarisch marschieren müssen und
ich glaube auch dass wir als das große
land mit der größten wirtschaftskraft
und der größten bevölkerung in der mitte
europas eine besondere aufgabe haben ein
deutscher bundeskanzler
eine deutsche bundesregierung
ich sage aber auch ein deutscher
bundestag und auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes können nicht ein
spiel spielen gegen brüssel oder gegen
andere länder in der europäischen union
für die nationale debatte nach dem motto
die sind alle falsch gewickelt ich gehe
da mal hin und sagt dem mal was sache
ist und kommen dann zurück so haben wir
es erreicht sondern wir sind schon
diejenigen die dafür sorge tragen müssen
dass der fortschritt und die
zukunftsfähigkeit europas auch gelingt
und dazu bekenne ich mich auch
die nächste freiheit frau es was
nehmen sie das mikro sonst hört man sie
leider gar nicht
bild wir haben gerade schon ihre zeit
als bürgermeister der freien und
hansestadt hamburg angesprochen und ich
finde es schön dass sie sich erinnern an
sitzungen zu wilhelmshaven aber nicht
mehr zum comic skandal dazu eine frage
was wissen sie über das
nicht
keine ahnung indem man sie wissen es er
als ich
die nächste frage hat dann unbedingt mal
nach rechts rüber wechsel from marshall
marshall von der rheinischen post ich
wollte sie bei den entlastungen noch
nicht ganz
raus lassen noch mal nachfragen
diese vorschläge von finanzminister
lindner zum abbau der kalten progression
haben eine intensive debatte über
soziale gerechtigkeit auch bei spd
grünen und fdp ausgelöst nominal werden
höhe einkommen ja höher entlastet als
kleine einkommen warum ist das sozial
gerecht
diese debatte wird ja gerne immer
jeweils aus verschiedenen blickwinkeln
betrachtet und ich glaube dass es gut
ist sie von ganz zu betrachten ich habe
neulich ein aufsatz an des früheren
finanzministers aus mecklenburg
vorpommern gelesen der politisch eher
nicht zu denjenigen die man einen
konservativen sozialdemokraten nennen
würden gehört und gesagt hat eigentlich
ist das völlig ok mit der sache mit der
kalten progression sowie ich dass die
letzten zwei mal gemacht habe weil er
darauf hingewiesen hat dass wenn man die
prozentsätze vergleicht es aber wieder
andersrum ist und deshalb gibt es eben
beide aspekte die prozentsätze und die
absoluten summen und es geht doch daran
dass wir eine gerechte lösung insgesamt
zustande bringen und dazu sind wir auch
gewählt und ich wiederhole noch mal für
mich geht es natürlich darum dass wir
denen helfen die wenig geld haben
deshalb also die längst getroffene
entscheidung dort wo das richtig knapp
ist mit dem wohngeld etwas zu tun indem
wir das dramatisch ausweiten indem wir
dafür sorge tragen dass auch die
heizkosten druck
perspektivisch dass die dort dauerhaft
eine rolle spielen dazu zählt dass wir
die frage von studierenden und rentnern
in den blick nehmen dazu zählt aber auch
dass wir die frage derjenigen blick
nehmen die als arbeitnehmer arbeitnehmer
ein
einkommen haben das auch nicht dazu
reicht jetzt mit diesem wechsel fällen
klar zu kommen da müssen wir helfen da
sind natürlich steuerliche maßnahmen
sehr sinnvoll neben denen die wir schon
ergriffen habe man die entlastung jetzt
im september kommt und die glaube ich
erst danach von allen auch wahrgenommen
wird und viel geld kostet die ist ja
über das steuersystem organisiert also
ich glaube dass wir da eine gute lösung
zustande kriegen werden wenn man alles
zusammengepackt und dazu habe ich sehr
konkrete vorstellungen bin mit sehr
vielen im gespräch das ist jetzt keine
sache wo wir neu anfangen zu denken
sondern wir arbeiten schon intensiv an
einer gesamtlösung und auch eine
präsentieren
zusatz die bedürftigen haben ja bisher
noch nicht so furchtbar viel gekriegt
und es gibt den vorschlag ein bürger
wählt über den inflationsausgleich
hinaus zu gehen
bis zu 40 euro noch mal oben drauf zu
packen gehen sie dann mit wir haben uns
als regierung vorgenommen dass wir eine
große reform zustande bringen und das
bürgergeld etablieren wir haben jetzt
gesagt das soll nicht irgendwann sondern
zum ersten jahren nur 23 der fall sein
dazu ist jetzt die ressort abstimmung
begonnen worden und selbstverständlich
wird dann am ende dieses prozesses auch
über die höhe entschieden werden müssen
und dazu gehört dann aber auch dass das
in den kontext eingeordnet wird den wir
gerade diskutieren wenn es darum geht
die bürgern und bürger zu entlasten und
deshalb wird das alles im zusammenhang
gedacht werden müssen um sicher auch
gemeinsam bewegt
das nächste frage stellt beliebige vorne
steht von reinhard schweizer fernsehen
es gibt ja im zusammenhang mit der
energie auch verhandlungen mit der
schweiz über ein solidaritäts abkommen
können sie das auch und wo man da steht
und wo es noch hakt
dann habe ich als nächstes auf meiner
liste herrn repinski
ist das richtige
mikrofon
herr bundeskanzler brandt in ski fahre
ich habe auch meine frage zu comics
warburg nächste woche ist ja am freitag
der
untersuchungsausschuss und kern des
ganzen wird ja auch sein wie die
gespräche verlaufen sein könnten
zwischen der marius und ihnen er war ja
als warburg chef 2016 als die gespräche
dann zum großteil auch stattfinden schon
in einem großen schlamassel und und
einer großen steuerrückzahlung
gegenübergestellt können sie vielleicht
uns mal hier vorab sagen an was aus
diesen gesprächen sie sich erinnern ich
habe zu diesen dingen ja sehr
umfangreich und viele stunden lang
stellung genommen und werde das wieder
tun ich habe
die auskünfte gegeben die möglich sind
aber ich will gerne ihre frage als
gelegenheit benutzen einmal auf
folgendes freundlich hinzuweisen das ist
jetzt seit zweieinhalb jahren ein thema
der journalistin für alle möglichen die
an dem thema arbeiten auch für den
ausschuss in hamburg es sind unglaublich
viele personen gehört worden das sind
unglaublich viele akten studiert worden
und wenn man jetzt die
presseberichterstattung über die
jeweiligen anhörung ein anderes verfolgt
denn es immer das ergebnis es hat keine
beeinflussung durch die politik gegeben
was die entscheidung betrifft ich bin
sicher dass diese erkenntnis nicht mehr
verändert werden wird nach zweieinhalb
jahren ist das ganz klar
so
setzten sie dann vielleicht trotzdem
noch mal sagen was sie sich erinnern
oder uns dann wenigstens erklären warum
sie das hier nicht sagen können ich habe
alles präzise beschrieben was möglich
ist und wer genau diese präzise
beschreibung die ich schon einmal
vorgetragen habe gerne wiederholen und
das auch tun dort wenn ich dazu gefragt
werde ich hätte das auch gerne viele
stunden tun aber ich sage noch einmal
die grundlage die vielleicht schwer für
diejenigen zu akzeptieren ist die sich
ich hoffe nicht wünschen aber zumindest
genau herausfinden wollten ob da was
anderes ist auch mal akzeptiert wird
zweieinhalb jahre unglaublich viele
anhörung unglaublich viele akten haben
nur ein ergebnis gebracht es gibt keine
erkenntnisse darüber dass es eine
politische beeinflussung gegeben hat
die nächste frage herr mühle
zu mühle bonner general-anzeiger ließ
kanzler unter welchen bedingungen wären
sie bereit vladimir putin wieder in
deutschland zu empfangen und in diesem
zusammenhang gerd schröder sagt er wolle
niemandem in der bundesregierung sein
vermittlungs top thema vielleicht können
ja noch mal nützlich sein kann herr
schröder für sie in dieser sache noch
mal nützlich sein
also über die frage wann putin mal
wieder in deutschland das habe ich mir
noch keine gedanken gemacht unter
welchen bedingungen war die frage nicht
wann ich glaube dass 1 doch ganz klar
ist dass er ist ein krieg der beendet
werden muss russland hat die ukraine
überfall versucht ein teil des
territoriums zu erobern das ist der
grund warum wir weltweit so viele
sanktionen beschlossen dass es der grund
warum wir jetzt viel mehr geld für die
bundeswehr aus geben und sie so
ausstatten dass wir uns gegen jeden
angriff wappnen können das ist der grund
warum wir die ukraine mit waffen
unterstützt und das was jetzt
stattfinden muss und das ist die aufgabe
die es jetzt geht das ist doch dass die
russland einsieht dass es sich
verständigen muss mit der ukraine und
dass das nicht hinauslaufen kann auf ein
diktat frieden wir ja wahrscheinlich am
anfang in den köpfen des russischen
präsidenten und seiner politischen
führungskräfte
gewesen ist das darf nicht klappen und
das wird auch nicht klappen da bin ich
ganz sicher wir alle gemeinsam werden
die ukraine unterstützen und das ist die
aufgabe um die es jetzt geht
sie noch mal nützlich sein ich wüsste
nicht also
letztendlich
habe ich zur kenntnis genommen dass im
hinblick auf die turbine die in
deutschland vorhanden ist und wo ich
mich entschlossen habe damit es kein
rätselraten darüber gibt dafür zu sorgen
dass jeder sie besichtigen kann und
jeder sinken sie es fertig dass die mal
importiert werden kann und das wäre man
verdienstvolles geschäft dafür zu sorgen
hört mal auf den scheinargumenten zu
sagen ihr wollt sie nicht haben nimmt
sie doch sie ist da
die nächste frage herr junge
stolz jungen
zwei fragen machen dass neun euro ticket
im öpnv ist ein großer erfolg ihrer
regierung welche weiteren erfolge ihrer
regierung wollen sie beenden
gar keine
offensichtlich schon weil das neue euro
ticket nicht vor dass man von vornherein
zeitlich befristet
könnte man ja ändern zweite frage
fordern sie eigentlich johannes kahrs
auf die herkunft der 200.000 euro in bar
nachzuweisen und der öffentlichkeit zu
begründen und haben sie jemals mit ihm
über die warburg bank gesprochen also
ich bin so neugierig wie sie und wirst
du natürlich gerne wo es herkommt aber
er wird mir wahrscheinlich weder mit
vitaminen eine auskunft aber das können
sie auch öffentlich fordern dass er das
tut weil sie wollen ja nicht dass dreck
an ihrer weißen weste hängenbleibt oder
das sei ein seriöser journalist sind ist
das ja ausgeschlossen
die nächste frage hat herr lincoln
bundeskanzler sie haben vorhin erwähnt
dass wir mit der energiewende
unabhängigkeit und den import fossiler
energien erreicht aber schlittert
deutschland nicht in neue abhängigkeiten
und zwar in diesem fall von china was
viele von den komponenten liefert die
für solarenergie windenergie und andere
zuständig sind vor diesem hintergrund
könnte sich deutschland überhaupt
sanktionen gegen china leisten wenn sich
der konflikt um taiwan weiter verschärft
zunächst mal über diese frage
entscheidet ja mit den rechtlichen
veränderung der letzten jahre auch die
europäische union haben ja auch im
hinblick auf einzelne fragen
entscheidung dieser art getroffen aber
was die
was die frage der abhängigkeit betrifft
ist das ein thema mit dem wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen übrigens auch
alle unternehmen denn das ist ja
eigentlich die grund lehre die man hier
leute im dritten semester
betriebswirtschaftslehre
hören aber dann offenbar wenn sie
management machen manchmal zwischendurch
vergessen dass man nicht alle eier in
einen korb nicht das gilt sowohl für die
importe also was die lieferketten
betrifft als auch die exporte dass man
diversifiziert und ich bin sicher dass
die deutsche wirtschaft diese
entscheidung längst getroffen hat und
wir werden sie dabei unterstützen
ansonsten ist es aus meiner sicht ein
notwendiger bestandteil unserer
nationalen sicherheitsstrategie an der
wir gerade arbeiten dass die frage der
unabhängigkeit unseres landes in
zentralen fragen was
lieferketten betrifft mit diskutiert
wird was rohstoffe und andere dinge
betrifft wir werden also schon dafür
gucken sorgen müssen dass lithium an
vielen stellen der welt
leben und das wäre es dann auch
exportierbar machen in länder wie
unseres so dass eben keine einseitigen
sondern diversifizierte beziehungen
existieren zur ganzen welt und das
gehört dazu
der nachfrage könnte sagen wann sie
eigentlich ein antrittsbesuch in china
machen oder ist der moment schon wegen
der spannung und talbahn ausgeschlossen
das ist ein termin über den wir leben
aber der noch nicht fixiert ist
dann die kollegin genau
den troxler rtl und n tv herr
bundeskanzler in der ampel gibt es
jedoch auch
immer wieder eine menge streitpunkte wo
vor allem auch die punkte von fdp und
grünen aufeinandertreffen vielleicht
können sie uns aus ihrer sicht mal sagen
wie die zusammenarbeit läuft und ob sie
sich sicher sind dass sie als ampel auch
die vier jahre durchhalten
zur letzten frage im jahr
ich habe sogar eine perspektive darüber
hinaus reicht wie ich schon bei
verschiedener gelegenheit gesagt habe
und will das gerne hier noch mal
unterstreichen es ist ja nicht so dass
mit dem koalitionsvertrag da ein
vereinigungsparteitag stattgefunden
hatte das sind drei unterschiedliche
parteien die auch mit unterschiedlichen
politischen programm angetreten sind zb
in der frage steuerpolitik kann man das
sehen muss man ja nur noch mal in die
wahlprogramme gucken das ist ja jetzt
nicht aus den köpfen der parteien für
stunden trotzdem haben wir es geschafft
ein sehr fortschritts und ihren und
wichtigsten probleme unseres landes
adressieren koalitionsvertrag zustande
zu kriegen denen wir jetzt stück für
stück und sogar mit großem tempo
abarbeiten und vorantreiben und das gilt
sogar für die tatsache dass große
herausforderung auf uns zugekommen sind
die nicht alle in dieser dimension oder
so absehbar waren corona als weitere
geschichte selbstverständlich absehbarer
aber im hinblick auf die tatsache dass
es ja vom natürlichen rahmenbedingungen
umhängt abhängt was da passiert der
virus entwicklung und den mutationen in
der welt virus mutation in der welt ist
das etwas wo wir einen gemeinsamen kurs
gefunden haben und jetzt auch gemeinsame
vorschläge vorgelegt haben die wir mit
den ländern zb diskutieren und das
gleiche gilt für viele andere fragen die
da sind ich glaube wenn man akzeptiert
dass die demokratie in deutschland sich
so verändert hat dass es jetzt
realistisch ist dass drei parteien das
land regieren dann sollte man auch
akzeptieren dass diese drei parteien
immer mal wieder von ausgangspositionen
herausgehen tim kompromisse und
vorschläge für die zukunft unseres
landes machen und das wird uns gelingen
und das gelingt uns ja auch ich habe
jetzt hier ganz viel gesagt von dem was
wir uns vorgenommen haben und was
passieren wird und schon passiert ist
und das ist ja schon ganz schön viel
wenn man das mit früheren jahren
vergleicht
dann die nächste folge hätten
ihn aber von der nachrichtenagentur
bloomberg hallo
den vergangenen wochen intensive
gespräche zwischen deutschland den g7
partnern zur umsetzung eines preis caps
in russland also einer preisobergrenze
um die gewinne des busses und seinen
namen auch mit schwellenländern
zu kappen sind sie nach diesen
gesprächen zu versichert dass das jetzt
bald kommen wird ist es hat es eine
detailreiche erreicht dass das
nachbar wird ich muss zugeben dass ich
nur die hälfte von dem was sie gesagt
haben verstanden hat aus irgendwelchen
technischen gründen
gemacht ich habe das gern stichwort
nicht mal verstanden warum sie mal ab
der ohne meine frage hat sich auf die
beratung von deutschland und den g 7
staaten zu einem neupreis camp bezogen
also einer preisobergrenze
konnte das wort europa skeptisch das war
natürlich
so und deshalb kann ich aber auch gerne
was sagen wir diskutieren über die frage
wie das geht das ist ja etwas das nur
funktioniert wenn das global
organisiert ist das wird man nicht
einseitig machen können sondern nur in
enger kooperation mit vielen anderen
weil sonst das ganze mehr läuft und
darüber sind gespräche im gange die sind
wegen der hohen technischen komplexität
noch nicht beendet und werden auch noch
eine zeitlang beanspruchen aber es wird
sehr intensiv daran gearbeitet dieses
gemeinsame vorhaben umzusetzen es wird
nur nicht funktionieren wenn es nur die
g7 staaten sich darauf verständigen da
sind ja noch andere bei die man als
partner druck
gesetzt
würden sie sagen das ist
aus heutiger sicht wahrscheinlicher ist
im vergleich zu dem gipfel ende juni
dass es umgesetzt werden kann weil es
gab ja viele gespräche in den letzten
wochen ja die sind ja nicht geführt
worden
weil das allgemein abzuwägen sondern
konkrete
handlung wege zu beschreiben und deshalb
ist da durchaus
fortschritt zu beobachten
denn die nächste frage stelle wo man
jetzt
so saniert man jetzt deutscher werden
und das ganze ich habe eine frage zu der
visa visa vergabe
stimmen sie ihren kolleginnen aus essen
finnland zu die jetzt ein ende ein stopp
der touristen dieser für uns bürger
fordern beziehungsweise eigentlich ist
es dann ein einreiseverbot für russen
inwiefern was ihre haltung dazu im
gefühl gehen sie damit
dass putins krieg
und
deshalb
tue ich mich mit diesem gedanken sehr
schwer
zusetzt wird nachfrage finden sie es
also
unproblematisch
oder putin anhänge auch in europa im
urlaub ihre sympathien kundtun und
dementsprechend die stimmung hier
anhalten wir haben ja sehr weitreichende
sanktionen beschlossen die auch viele
viele konkrete personen und oligarchen
und unterstützer des macht netzwerkes in
russland betreffen und das werden wir
sicherlich auch fortsetzen das wäre
würde ja gerade diese maßnahmen er in
ihrer wirksamkeit absprechen wenn es
jetzt sich gegen alle richtig auch ganz
unschuldige
tanz mit der nächsten fall
frank jordan sap
es hat information jahre waren kritik
daran gegeben dass deutschland mit
russland energie geschäfte gemacht hat
trotz aller warnungen der verbündeten
halten sie diese kritik die auch ihre
partei betrifft im nachhinein für
berechtigt und resultiert daraus eine
besondere verantwortung deutschlands für
die unterstützung der ukraine bei seiner
verteidigung gegen russland
für mich ist es
sehr klar dass wir
bei den entscheidungen der letzten jahre
und jahrzehnte früher die entscheidung
getroffen hätte treffen sollen die wir
jetzt getroffen haben nämlich dass wir
uns im pott infrastrukturen schaffen mit
dem wir jederzeit die anbieter wechseln
und sie diversifizieren können und das
stellen wir jetzt sicher schön wäre
gewesen das wäre schon so dann hätten
wir jetzt nur das problem der hohen
preise aber nicht das problem der
sicherheit der energieversorgung
und das ist glaube ich das was wir jetzt
zu recht ändern
nachfrage schmerz ist ident das
weiterhin deutsche unternehmen für gas
aus russland bezahlen
und sie ihre turbine sogar medienwirksam
kraftcom aufbringen müssen
aus meiner sicht ist es so dass wir
zurecht als europäische union als g7
entschieden haben dass es keine
sanktionen gibt die das gas im pott
betreffen weil die abhängigkeit
insbesondere vieler länder im osten
europas sehr sehr hoch ist ob wir haben
einen teil unserer energieversorgung der
aus russischem gas kommt wir haben ja
auch norwegisches niederländisches gas
wir schaffen jetzt die möglichkeiten aus
aller welt über die helfen in
großbritannien den niederlanden belgien
und frankreich gas nach deutschland zu
importieren und tun das ja auch schon
und wir schaffen die strukturen die uns
in die lage versetzen dass wir über die
norddeutschen häfen in
wilhelmshaven in stade in brunsbüttel in
lubmin gas in das deutsche gasnetz
importieren können für deutschland aber
auch viele länder die gar keine
küstenlinie haben und deshalb auf die
importmöglichkeiten über deutsche die
deutsche küste auch für sich selber
angewiesen sind
denn die nächste frage hier vorne der
kollegen
einander in italien herr bundeskanzler
finanzminister haben sie betont dass
next generation einen schritt zur
diskussion der europäischen union ist
würden sie heute die sind diese
bewertungen wiederholen und welche
schritte sind notwendig um diese
fiskalunion zu erhalten schönen dank für
ihre frage weil sie mit der gelegenheit
gibt noch mal darauf hinzuweisen was ich
bei dieser gelegenheit gesagt habe wenn
mich das der moment um dem es da geht
der ist dass wir uns deswegen
weil wir dieses recovery programm auf
den weg gebracht haben verständigen
müssen wie wir die rückzahlung der von
der eu aufgenommenen kredite
organisieren wie wichtig und richtig das
ist sieht man daran dass die
entscheidung über einen namen die es
ermöglichen dass zwischen
spätestens 2028 und
2058 die rückzahlung organisiert wird
noch nicht getroffen ist also wirklich
das echt harte programm über die frage
wie kriegen wir die ungefähr 13
milliarden euro rate die jedes jahr da
dann fällig wird für die europäische
union organisiert
in der debatte die hierzulande und ich
glaube manchmal mit falschen hoffnungen
verbunden anderswo geführt wird geht es
um die frage durch kreditaufnahme mir
ging es immer um die frage how to die
credits und das ist das was aus meiner
sicht der entscheidende punkt ist dass
wir ansonsten ja hier haben ist dass wir
eine gemeinsame haltung der
bundesregierung zum europäischen
stabilitäts und wachstumspakt haben
darüber haben wir uns miteinander
verständigt ein gemeinsames papier dass
wir auch an die europäische union
geschickt haben produziert das
öffentlich ist auf verschiedenen
webseiten und dass der finanzminister
vor kurzem vorgestellt dessen botschaft
ist wir wollen im rahmen des geltenden
paktes den wir nicht grundsätzlich
ändern wollen aber die möglichkeit mit
der flexibilität die wir auch in der
bisherigen krisenbekämpfung hatten für
die zukunft weiter nutzen kurze frage
welche einfluss können die wachsende
opposition auf die politik der ezb in
ihrer koalition haben können also die
die wachsende position auch gegen das
letzte projekt
und wie schätzen sie auch die politische
krise im moment in dem wagen für die
zukunft nicht sehr viel spannung das
sind zwei ganz große fragen also die
bundesrepublik deutschland und auch die
jetzige bundesregierung schätzen die
unabhängigkeit der europäischen
zentralbank
manchmal wird das ja vergessen aber es
war das deutsche anliegen dass die
europäische zentralbank unabhängig ist
von staatlichem einfluss und deshalb
werden wir diese unabhängigkeit auch
verteidigen auch in der frage wie wir
kommentieren mit einzel- entscheidungen
umgehen wir haben eine verantwortung die
wir immer zu beachten haben im hinblick
auf konkrete entscheidung weil wir
prüfen ob
das mit dem
vertraglichen rahmenbedingungen
vereinbar ist was dann entscheidung im
einzelnen getroffen ist das machen wir
sehr routiniert und sehr regelmäßig und
der präsident der bundesbank hat sich
zur bewertung der letzten entscheidungen
ja auch sehr konkret geäußert es gab
hier zwei die eine rolle gespielt haben
nämlich einmal der
größere zinsschritt der gemacht worden
ist worüber er sich sehr gefreut hat und
die sehr abgewogene entscheidung über
die frage was man tun könnte wenn eine
spezielle situation eintritt und dann
eventuell vielleicht möglicherweise was
zu tun ist
er ist es ja nicht
was die situation in italien betrifft
möchte ich noch mal sagen ich glaube
dass der ministerpräsident ein großer
politiker ist dass er eine großartige
arbeit für italien leistet und geleistet
hat und dass seine regierungstätigkeit
dem land sehr gut tut
denn die nächste frage von marc meier
ist das sofort
die kinder mag mancher evangelischer
pressedienst epd herr bundeskanzler ich
will noch einmal auf diese entlastung
debatte zurück kommen sie haben jetzt
eben gesagt wir werden viel machen auch
für leute die wenig haben und dann haben
sie im verlauf dieser stunde gesagt wir
werden dann zusammen rechnen was wir
finanzieren können jetzt sagt so jemand
wie der chef vom diw fratzscher 70
prozent dieser steuerentlastungen gehen
an 30 prozent der bürger mit den
höchsten einkommen ich wüsste gerne von
ihnen wo ihr fokus liegt ihr eigener
fokus bei dieser frage der entlastung
mein fokus liegt auf den wenigen
mit dem ich ein großes gespräch begonnen
habe im letzten jahr über das thema des
respekts
respekt ist für mich das was in unserer
gesellschaft leider zu viel abhanden
gekommen ist und was aber wichtig ist
für den zusammenhalt unserer
gesellschaft und damit meine ich
diejenigen die jeden tag berufstätig
sind und manchmal sehr wenig geld oder
nur normal viel geld verdienen ich habe
das gesagt die sechs millionen bürgern
und bürger die jetzt durch eine
mindestlohn- erhöhung
auf 12 euro am ersten oktober
profitieren werden und natürlich werden
wir deren wirtschaftliche und
finanzielle verhältnisse auch bei den
entlastungs paketen ganz genau in den
blick nehmen deshalb gebildes wohngeld
geredet deshalb rede ich über die frage
steuerliche entlastung und andere
entlastungsmöglichkeiten auch gerade in
diesem zusammenhang ganz deutlich wenn
ich mich jetzt nicht verrechnet habe
mehr passieren wenn man das vor so
vielen leuten kurzem hintergrund tut
aber dann ist es ja so dass bei einer 40
stunden woche und
12 euro ein einkommen von knapp über
2.000 ich glaube 2080 euro brutto
rauskommen das ist ja immer noch nicht
viel geld ich glaube das muss man sich
klar machen
und das zweite ist das
[Musik]
natürlich auch bewegen diejenigen die
darüber liegen ich habe gesprochen von
den frauen und männern in deutschland
die tolle wichtige arbeit leisten für
2800 3200 euro brutto für vier manchmal
auch mehr geld aber wenn man jetzt die
ganze familieneinkommen zusammenrechnung
was alles so zu bewältigen ist ist
ziemlich klar ist dass sie keine
rücklagen haben und dass sie sich bei
den steigenden preisen jetzt schon
gedanken machen wie sie dadurch kommen
sollen und da ist die botschaft noch mal
wir werden euch nicht alleine lassen und
das ist eine haltung die mir wichtig ist
darum habe ich über das thema des
respekts für diese arbeitnehmer und
arbeitnehmer in unserer gesellschaft
gesprochen für die selbstständigen die
auch in diesen einkommenskategorien sind
und auch manchmal kämpfen müssen und das
wird auch meine tätigkeit als
sozialdemokratischer kanzler immer
bestimmen aber gleichzeitig ist es so
dass ich sagen kann dass wir ein
gesamtpaket schnüren dass all diese
fragen adressiert wird eine gemeinsame
leistung der ganzen koalition sein
zusatz
eine nachfrage die sozialverbände
fordern oder sozialverbände nicht alle
fordern an den tisch geholt zu werden
weil der konzertierten aktion damit die
gruppen die idee vertreten eben da auch
vertreten sind werden sie das
noch mal einen schönen dank für den
hinweis auf die konzertierte aktion denn
die gehört natürlich zu den ganz
wichtigen
instrumenten mit denen wir auf die
jetzige preis situation reagieren denn
das wird ja nicht nur mit staatlichem
handeln alleine gelingen sondern da geht
es ja mal ein zusammenspiel von
gewerkschaften und
unternehmensverbänden und
arbeitgeberverbänden mit der politik
vertreten durch die sachverständigen des
sachverständigenrates den die bundesbank
aber eben auch die deutsche
bundesregierung und in dieser
konstellation wollen wir das fortsetzen
und es letztendlich das anknüpfen an
eine der wichtigsten kraftquellen
unseres landes bedeutet nämlich die
sozialpartnerschaft
dann habe ich herrn bush meiner liste
thomas vitzthum mit ich hatte sie für
ein buch gehalten dass wir gewinnen
mussten aber er
hat sich erkannt gefüllt
der blick hat gereicht
herr bundeskanzler sie haben heute aber
auch bei siemens energy den eindruck
erweckt als würden sie voll auf allen
sätzen sind für sie pipelineprojekte
jedweder art
nicht mehr sinnvoll weil sie eine
infrastruktur zementieren die sie durch
die energiewende obsolet machen wollen
nein ich glaube wir brauchen projekte
die sich auf dem parkplatz beschäftigen
wenn ich jetzt mal eine ganz konkrete
benennen darf die pipeline zwischen
rostock und spät ist eine mit mir hatte
sehr viel beschäftige damit deren
leistungsfähigkeit dramatisch gesteigert
wird und er hat so haben wir sehr viele
sehr konkrete diskussionen mit allen
möglichen beteiligten geführt und
bereiten vor wie wir das möglich machen
können ich habe mich sehr beschäftigt
mit einer leider heute
für uns alle dramatisch vermissten
pipeline
nämlich der pipeline die man hätte baum
soll zwischen portugal spanien durch
frankreich nach mitteleuropa die würde
jetzt einen massiven beitrag zur
entlastung und entspannung der
versorgungslage beitragen und deshalb
habe ich mit den beiden kollegen
entspannen und portugal aber auch im
gespräch mit dem französischen
präsidenten und mit dem
kommissionspräsidenten sehr dafür
geworben dass wir zum beispiel ein
solches projekt anpacken und es wird
sicherlich auch weitere verbindungen
geben die zwischen
afrika und europa dazu beitragen dass
wir eine diversifizierte versorgung
haben was ihre frage der verfestigung
betrifft halte ich das für ein tun
wir werden wenn wir wasserstoff als
einen wichtigen rohstoff in deutschland
behandeln für die energieproduktion aber
auch für die industriellen prozesse
den großen umfang deutschland
produzieren können das hat etwas mit
elektrolyse zu tun und dem aus meiner
sicht dringend notwendigen der
elektrolyse in deutschland wo ich mit
vielen dabei den zu besprechen die das
gut funktionieren kann
sondern dann wird es eben auch um den
import von wasserstoff nach deutschland
den auch dafür werden wir hat dann
infrastrukturen brauchen so dass es auch
sinn macht aldi mg terminals die wir
jetzt bauen die pipelines dem norden
deutschlands bauen die werden ja später
auch
weiterentwickelt um investiert genutzt
werden können für die wasserstoff
importe die uns helfen werden und wir
haben ja gar nicht so viel zeit denn wir
wollen ja schon 2045 co2 neutral
wirtschaften nur für diejenigen die sich
das alles zu einfach vorstellen daneben
spielt eine große rolle dabei wir haben
600 terawattstunden strom die wir heute
produzieren wir werden schon zum ende
des jahrzehnts 800 brauchen und am ende
des übernächsten jahrzehnt
wahrscheinlich die doppelte menge etwa
16 100 terawattstunden strom damit co2
neutrale industrie möglich ist und
deshalb ist der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien so wichtig der aber auch indem
wir das tun immer billiger immer
industrialisierter wird um uns deshalb
eine sichere und in der perspektive dann
auch nicht zu teure stromversorgung
gewährleisten hat
herr david begg
guten tag herr bundeskanzler sie
sprachen davon dass sie versäumnisse
abarbeiten wollte das haben sie so
betont und
auch dass sie sich mit wickelt daran
erinnern konnten dass sie den chef einer
großen bank mehrmals getroffen haben
er hat aber 47 millionen euro vom
deutschen staat geklaut und danach hat
ihr apparat in hamburg
haben sie angewiesen darauf noch mal zu
schauen und nach aus dieser angeklagte
banker das geklaute geld erhalten
meine frage ist das doch eigentlich
nicht glaubwürdig er
vor allem ist es nicht glaubwürdig wenn
man eine frage fakten besteht nicht
erwiesen sind nach zweieinhalb jahren
recherche die auch sie ja sehr intensiv
machen und doch immer wieder mit diesem
thema rost was doch bewiesen deshalb ist
nicht ist ist es nicht so wie sie sagen
es gibt keinen einzigen hinweis darüber
nach dem man all die jeden beteiligten
gehört hat dass es eine einflussnahme
der politik auf diese entscheidung
gegeben hat und im übrigen nur der
vollständigkeit halber und weil das hier
ja öffentlich berichtet wird weil die
steuern die der staat verlangt hat hatte
auch eingezogen ja so etwas zu sein was
bewiesen ist was sie auch wissen
es doch nach ihrer anweisung nachdem sie
den mann doch getroffen haben mehrmals
habe sie sich erst mal nicht erinnern
kommt und jetzt wird
danach durfte er das von seiner bank
geklauten geld behalten das ist also
eine tatsache das sind fakten das ist
mein das visa das ist keine tatsache und
wenn sie können sich darauf verlassen
dass ich nicht zu den leuten zähle die
so was machen aber sie würden diese
tatsachenbehauptungen nicht erhärten
können
wenn sie müssten die nächste frist
würden sie nicht erhalten können wenn
sie es müssten bedenken sie daß wenn sie
so was sagt die nächste frage die
kolleginnen knapp dahinter
war anna rettig vom nachrichtenportal
watson der bundeskanzler sie haben jetzt
mehrmals schon die studierenden erwähnt
wenn es um die entlastung beim thema
inflation oder energiekrise ging es gibt
natürlich auch noch andere junge
menschen also schülerinnen und schüler
beispielsweise auszubildende auch
arbeitsuchende
wir sind jetzt bisher alle im großteil
bei den entlastungs paketen die bisher
geschnürt wurden außen vorgelassen
worden würden sie als bundeskanzler
beim kommenden großen gesamtpaket ihren
minister innen denn künftig ein bisschen
mehr auf die finger schauen dass die
jugend nicht verarmt in deutschland
wir haben uns
darüber schon sehr viele gedanken
gemacht die gehirne sind auch in den
koalitionsvertrag der jetzigen
bundesregierung eingeflossen zum
beispiel eine brücke formen davon haben
wir auch schon das umgesetzt was bereits
in kraft getreten ist und eine
verbesserung für viele mit sich gebracht
hat wir haben auch regelung getroffen
die dazu beitragen sollen dass diese
dort als wieder eine situation eintritt
wo viele die
ihren job verlieren in dem studium
plötzlich in finanzielle notlage geraten
besser ist es was wir zuletzt hatten
also ganz konkret eine reaktion auch auf
die corvette 19 paare leben dieser frage
und natürlich gehört dazu auch dass wir
für uns in den blick nehmen können wir
die mit der situation umgehen dass das
ja auch für viele junge leute eine ganz
beschränkende situation gewesen ist und
so einer existentiellen wichtigen
lebensphase vom weniger kontakt zu haben
sich mit dem freund nicht treffen zu
können da ist ja auch viel verloren
gegangen
an möglichkeiten der zusammenarbeit der
freizeit wenn die aktionen des sich
kennenlernens das leben kennenlernt und
deshalb haben wir schon in der letzten
regierung maßnahmen getroffen die die
länder in die lage versetzen sollen da
ein bisschen was nachzuholen auch sowohl
was freizeiten betrifft als auch was
schulische qualifikation betrifft und
deshalb gehört es auch zu unseren
entscheidungen dass wir gesagt haben so
wie wir die lage jetzt verstehen während
neue schulschließungen zum beispiel
keine adäquate reaktion auf die pandemie
entwickeln
zu setzen jetzt aber um konkrete
entlastungspläne in bezug auf die
inflation und die gaskrise wenn ich
jetzt konkret werde die
kindergelderhöhung sind ungefähr acht
euro im monat sie hatten eben gerade vom
bafög gesprochen das sind ungefähr sechs
euro im monat mehr glauben sie dass die
teller füllt
ich habe ja gesagt dass wir alle
bevölkerungsgruppen bei unseren plänen
die wir im blick die wir haben in den
blick nehmen werden und dass wir
versuchen werden eine gesamtlösung zu
entwickeln die und das habe ich
ausdrücklich gesagt auch die jungen
leute die studierenden in den blick
nimmt genauso wie zum beispiel die
renten
dann die nächste frage jessen
herr scholz sie sind der kanzler die
größte krise seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
zu bewältigen hat dazu möchte ich gerne
wissen dann haben sie und in welcher
form von der richtlinienkompetenz in
besonderer weise gebraucht gebracht so
braucht gemacht mir ist er innerlich
das 100 milliarden sondervermögen würde
ich als eine solche durchsetzung
betrachten wo noch oder haben sie es vor
es ist gut dass ich sie habe
aber natürlich nicht in der form dass
sich jemand einen brief schreibe bitte
herr minister machen sie das folgende
sondern ist es meine aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass die regierung die wichtigen
entscheidungen trifft die uns in die
lage versetzen auf diese krise zu
reagieren und allein unser gespräch dass
wir hier heute führen hätte er gezeigt
wie weit reichende maßnahmen wie er auf
den weg gebracht haben die weitreichende
maßnahmen für die zukunft wäre bereits
vorbereiten und das geschieht natürlich
weil ich ständig mit allen beteiligten
sprechen aber es bleibt eine
gesamtleistung der regierung wenn es gut
läuft und so ist es ja auch mit dem
sondervermögen das haben wir durch
bekommen sogar mit hilfe der opposition
was ja wichtig war wegen der
grundgesetzänderung wir haben es durch
bekommen dass wir jetzt diese risiken
tempo schritte bei der energiewende auf
den weg bringen dass wir die ganzen
entscheidung wie gehen wir mit der
möglichen gast mangel lage um
rechtzeitig getroffen wurden ich habe es
bereits berichte ich habe im dezember
wirtschaftsministerium gefragt und
kanzleramt was ist eigentlich wenn wir
kein gast kriegen und wir arbeiten schon
seit januar daran dass ganz konkret zu
machen wir treffen uns sehr sehr häufig
heute zum beispiel wieder aber ganz
regelmäßig und besprechen diese
konkreten situation und das was ich gut
finde ist dass es der regierung trotz
dieser großen herausforderung die mit
diesen themen verbunden ist gelungen ist
die richtigen entscheide zu treffen in
großer geschwindigkeit und immer
rechtzeitig nachfrage
zu den phänomenen der krise gehört dass
die soziale ungleichheit in deutschland
vermögensungleichheit
einkommensungleichheit fähigkeit mit
krisen fertig zu werden
doch immer weiter auseinander zu stecken
ist empirisch nachweisbar es kann einem
sozialdemokratischen kanzler nicht
gefallen was tun sie explizit um dieses
weitere öffnen sozialen und finanziellen
schere zu verhindern
zunächst mal ist es so dass wir ein
gutes wirtschaftliches eine gute
wirtschaftsentwicklung braucht mit einem
hohen beschäftigungsstand den letzteren
haben wir die gute
wirtschaftsentwicklung können wir auch
gewährleisten wir müssen aber durch
diese zeit kommen wo es jetzt ein
bisschen eng wird mit der
energieversorgung im winter und deshalb
ist vom sparen von gas und energie
angefangen bis zu all den anderen
maßnahmen die ich geschildert habe und
hier nicht wiederholen will das
natürlich was wir tun damit wir das
sichern und für die zukunft darauf
aufbauen können
dass wir unsere industrielle
transformation vorantreiben ist die
grundlage dafür dass das gute sichere
arbeitsplätze für die zukunft gibt und
dass wir dann aber so weit reichende
reformen machen wie ich sie hier
forschen skizziert habe wie den
mindestlohn die verbesserung der
erwerbsminderungsrenten die
stabilisierung des rentenniveaus wie die
reformen im bereich des bafögs die
bereitschaft etwas zu tun für
studierende und rentner die große
wohngeldreform die bürger geld reform
dass wir die kindergrundsicherung als
perspektive dieser legislaturperiode im
blick haben das sind ganz konkrete
maßnahmen die dazu beitragen sollen dass
es genau andersrum läuft als sie
befürchten und genau auf diesen
maßnahmen werde ich auch aufgreifen ich
wiederhole noch mal das ist für mich
zentral die fragestellung vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger liegen nicht im
öffentlichen fokus das was sie für ihren
täglichen lebensunterhalt für ihre
lebensperspektiven brauchen wird nicht
jeden tag überall diskutiert im
augenblick ändert sich das ein bisschen
durch die inflation aber es ist ja doch
so dass
das eigentlich nicht jeden tag vor
die von mir eben erwähnte verbesserung
der erwerbsminderungsrente findet stadt
kostet milliarden kann aber niemand also
könnte sein dass die meisten bürger
davon nichts mitgekriegt haben weil das
gar nicht gegenstand öffentlicher
debatten
problemstellungen erläuterung und
wahrnehmung ist trotzdem müssen wir uns
darum kümmern und trotzdem tun wir das
das habe ich eben beschrieben die
nächste frage herr koch
da hatten sie sich gar nicht gemeldet
ich hatte sie auf der liste dann eher
ist man
ja herr bundeskanzler georg erstmal vom
tagesspiegel ich möchte doch auch noch
ein haken beim fall war weil man muss
sich hat die abläufe anschauen das gab
das treffen im november 216 sieht
heraeus und herren harburg danach haben
sie ja nur los angerufen und gesagt wie
möglich im brief den er ihn überreicht
hat ohne weitere bemerkung an den
finanzsenator weiter geben und danach
rund 740 millionen erlassen und im jahr
2017 gab es eine große spende an die spd
und die frage ist jetzt ja auch das
solarium unserem tag geschrieben hat
er aber gras gebinden gebeten sie noch
mal zufrieden vor diesem treffen im
november hat dieses mit herrn haas
stattgefunden ja oder nein
alles was ich dazu berichten kann habe
ich bereits berichtet und werde ich im
nächsten woche im ausschuss noch einmal
berichten das steht auch schon überall
nachzulesen weil es darüber keine neuen
geheimen fakten gibt und das ist ja
glaube ich das bemerkenswerte wir haben
eine situation wo jetzt zweieinhalb
jahre versucht worden ist etwas zu
identifizieren was es nicht gibt nämlich
eine politische einflussnahme auf diese
entscheidung und damit bleibe ich es hat
diese politische entscheidung
einflussnahme nicht gegeben und ich
werde sehr viele stunden lang und da
freue ich mich auch darauf alle fragen
noch einmal beantworten am nächsten
freitag vermutlich sich anzuhören und
das ist alles gute frage aber es tauchen
jetzt ja immer wieder hat auch durch die
ermittlungen der staatsanwaltschaft neue
erkenntnisse auf die zuständige
finanzbeamte das in chat nachrichten
aufgetaut spricht von einem teuflischen
plan und nochmal die nachfrage sie
können also ausschließen dass sie vor
ihrem treffen mit herrn olearius und
herrnburg erst danach in der folge gab
es dann eben ihre entscheidung nicht
zurückzufordern die 740 millionen dass
herr k sie nicht gebraucht hat dass es
kein weiteres treffen mit herrn cars in
diesem herbst 2016 gegeben hat zwischen
ihnen beiden zum teil war
alles was ich berichte können habe ich
bereits berichtet und das könnte ich
gerne noch mal wiederholen und ich
wiederhole auch noch mal was ich eben
gesagt habe es ist in der tat so dass
man eigentlich irgendwann mal nach
zweieinhalb jahren sagen muss wir haben
jetzt wirklich alle scheinwerfer
eingeschaltet wir haben jeden befragt
wir haben jede unterlage eingesehen und
wir haben herausgefunden es gibt kein
einziges indiz für eine einflussnahme
durch politische entscheidungsträger auf
das was dort jeweils fachlich erörtert
und entschieden worden ist in der
finanzverwaltung
ich habe keinen anspruch darauf dass
irgendjemand mal sagt okay zweieinhalb
jahre habe ich es versucht rauszukriegen
ich habe es nicht geschafft aber ich
gebe zu ich bin ein mensch genau ich
freute mich wenn das der ein oder andere
mal über sein herz bringt die nächste
fahrgast
für außenpolitik als freier journalist
hätte ich gerne einmal so wollen ein
rettungshilfe für blick in den nahen
osten werden sie als übernahm mit ihrer
vorgängerin die staatsraison
unverändert fortführen also das
schutzpaket für israel ganz grob
beschrieben trotz der veränderten
israelischen regierungspolitik mehr
gezielte präventive
erschießungen tötungen und in dem
zusammenhang erschließt sie ihnen die
gemein
für ungleiche diskussion in deutschland
zu israel politik zum antisemitismus
respektable persönlichkeiten wie die
früheren botschafters stein und prima
die chefin des einstein forums susan
nehmen und moshe zimmermann tauchen
überhaupt nicht auch sein mag in einer
kolumne der faz wir schließlich ihnen
das
und es an mir ist mir da etwas zu
erschließen das weiß ich nicht ich
möchte aber gerne sagen dass sie recht
haben wir werden die israel politik in
großer kontinuität
fortsetzen es ist wichtig dass wir den
staat israel und seine existenz sichern
und unterstützen da haben wir als land
eine große verantwortung
dann habe ich ein wrestler auf meiner
liste
herr bundeskanzler sie haben sie haben
ja
sie haben ja anklingen lassen wie
entsetzt sie waren angesichts der
versäumnisse die sie im amt vorgefunden
haben was die energiesicherheit
deutschlands angeht und sie haben auch
darauf verwiesen dass die sich schon
über viele jahre für lng terminals
eingesetzt haben nichtsdestoweniger
haben sie über jahrzehnte verantwortung
getragen in der partei die zusammen mit
der union die fatale abhängigkeit von
russland in der energieteam
verantwortet sehen sie und sie waren sie
waren in der vergangenen qualifikation
sie bei sich selbst an fast ein wenig
zerknirscht zu sein oder wiegt in das
tor
das ist durchaus etwas zu dem ich fähig
bin obwohl das gegenteilige gerüchte
gibt aber
etwas ganz konkretes sagen ich glaube es
ist so wie ich es versucht habe foren
darzulegen jedes land jedes unternehmen
ist gut beraten sich in eine sich so
aufzustellen dass man jederzeit
wechseln kann was seiner lieferanten
betrifft übrigens auch was seine exporte
betrifft dass man also diversifiziert
und
das glaube ich wäre und würde uns jetzt
einfacher fallen wenn wir die
infrastrukturen geschaffen hätten die
man dazu benötigt damit dass jederzeit
möglich ist die meisten ziemlich viele
länder der welt kriegen ja ihr gast zum
beispiel nicht über pipelines sondern
über schiffe und das hätte uns auf den
einfall bringen können dass wir und sei
es als ein staatlich finanziertes
investment terminals schaffen mit dem
das jederzeit möglich ist falls man mal
in schwierigkeiten gerät wirklich mal
orientieren an den problemen der
italienischen regierung dort ist viele
viele jahre gast bezogen wurden aus dem
iran
dann hat man diese abhängigkeit beendet
und jetzt landete man in der neuen gott
sei dank ist das geografisch dort
möglich jetzt aus dem norden afrikas
neue quellen zu erschließen
aber das zeigt ja das problem ist nicht
nur unser ist dass es überall in der
welt das wir gucken müssen sind wir
technisch in der lage schnell auf andere
umzusteigen und was muss man dazu tun
und für viele unternehmen wird es schon
so sein dass sie dann sagen müssen
selbst wenn die konzentration auf einen
zulieferer an einer stelle
die billigste ist habe ich lieber zwei
oder drei an unterschiedlichen stellen
und bei sachen die ganz zentral sind
vielleicht auch immer einen fuß in
europa damit dass etwas ist auf das sich
unmittelbar zugriff haben kann und so
sollten wir die fragen auch lösen wenn
es um unsere export und import
strategien geht und auch das andere
rohstoffe betrifft als jetzt nun kurse
öl und gas sondern die frage wie kann
man das sicher stellen dass wir auch bei
den neuen dingen die wir brauchen kobalt
lithium viele andere stoffe immer in der
lage sind das was wir brauchen auch zu
bekommen dass wir auch im hinblick auf
produktionskapazitäten die für die
industrielle entwicklung wichtig sind
dort auch neue entscheidungen treffen
sieht man daran dass wir jetzt ja
uns im koalitionsvertrag bereit erklärt
haben
milliarden zu investieren um
halbleiterproduktion in deutschland
möglich zu machen die intel ansiedlung
in magdeburg ist ja nur der erste große
baustein da werden viele kleine aber
auch noch größere weitere folgen an
anderen stellen die dazu beitragen soll
dass wir es schaffen können dass diese
abhängigkeit zum beispiel reduzieren und
das muss man auch bei vielen anderen
themen so machen und der wichtigste
schritt zur reduktion unserer
abhängigkeit
ist ganz sicher der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien da bin ich fest
von überzeugt dass das das wichtigste
ist was wir machen können um uns
souveränität für die zukunft zu
verschaffen und gleichzeitig das zu tun
was für unsere wirtschaftliche und
zukunft wichtig ist nämlich
erneuerbare energien auszubauen und das
kindern zu schützen
tragen vieles von dem was sie sagen
klingt ja zumindest das freute sich
naheliegend würde sagen das ist etwas
aufzuarbeiten gibt das weiß in einer m
cat kommission oder auf andere weise die
versäumnisse wir zu einer wirklich
schwierigen lage für dieses land geführt
haben und zum teil zu einer schwierigen
und lage in anderen ländern was die
irgendwie geklärt werden müssen und auch
gesehen werden muss wäre wenn sie denn
profitiert hat
glaube ich nicht aber will ich auch
niemanden daran hindern ist ja nicht
sache der regierung aber das was ich
gerne sagen möchte ist wir müssen uns ja
auch als gesellschaft in die lage
versetzen solche sachen rational zu
erwägen meine als durch eine
indiskretion bekannt wurde dass ich sehr
wurde im namen der gesamten
bundesregierung vorgeschlagen hatte lng
terminals zu bauen im gespräch mit den
vereinigten staaten von amerika
haben sich unisono fast alle
natürlich niemand hier im raum aber sag
mal fast alle aufgeregt und gesagt was
und haben dann auch noch das mit der
falschen kommunikation fracking gas
versehen und versucht die debatte zu
töten über die steuerfinanzierte
unterstützung des baus von 5 festivals
an den norddeutschen küsten
und
dass die debatte nicht zu ende ist merkt
man ja an der frage die der geschätzte
kollege leben gestellt hat die ich jetzt
nicht ganz verhallt meine sondern das
ist ja eine gesellschaftliche debatte
wenn wir neue pipelines bauen
verfestigen wir damit nicht die fossile
infrastruktur meine antwort ist nein
aber wir werden ja uns jetzt auch so
aufstellen müssen dass wir auch in fünf
jahren und zehn jahren die frage von
ihnen oder einem kollegen von in der
dann an der stelle sitzt beantworten
können haben sie jetzt bedacht dass es
ja bis es soweit ist dass wir alles
machen mit erneuerbaren energien und mit
wasserstoff mit phase gibt in der wehr
falls es irgendwo hakt an der
einstellung unserer import kufra
strukturen von woanders etwas bekommen
müssen dass da dann schon jetzt auch
zweifel sind oder die debatten wie jetzt
über die frage erschließung neuer
gasfelder in afrika oder anderswo
stattfinden die sind ja nur ein leuchten
wenn man sie auf dieses kleine schema
beschränkt
dass er im hinblick auf langfristige
perspektiven gilt
sondern die sind ja müssen ja auch
betrachtet werden vor dem hintergrund
kann uns bis wir durch sind mit den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien in der
zwischenzeit noch was passieren und die
antwort ist das sollte nicht sein da
müssen wir alle entscheidungen jetzt
treffen das heißt aus dieser
vergangenheit muss die lehre gezogen
werden dass die infrastrukturelle
sicherheit unserer in unserer versorgung
ein thema ist und ich komm doch mal
zurück auf das was ich von auf eine
frage beantworten durfte
in der sicherheitsstrategie der
bundesregierung wird die frage
unabhängigkeit von rohstofflieferungen
um von anderen zulieferungen die
essenziell sind für unsere
wirtschaftliche stabilität eine rolle
spielten und dann nicht konsequenzen los
wenn ich das gerne ergänzen darf
angela wefers börsen zeitung herr
bundeskanzler ich habe mal eine frage zu
steuern im zusammenhang mit dem
entlastungspaket wird immer wieder auch
diskutiert steuern erhöhen etwa eine
über gewinn steuer einzuführen für
besonders erfolgreiche und oder oder
profitieren die unternehmen die von
dieser situation profitieren da auch
eine erhöhung der einkommensteuersätze
für die besonders gut verdienenden
menschen ist das auch teil des über kann
das teils entlastungspaket es sei das
umzusetzen was die letzte frage
einkommenssteuer betrifft gab es ja
unterschiedliche konzepte der parteien
die zur bundestagswahl angetreten sind
und auch derjenigen die jetzt eine
regierung gebildet haben und wir haben
uns darauf verständigt keine solche
einkommensteuer erhöhung zu machen für
spitzenverdiener
das stand im spd wahlprogramm in dem der
grünen aber nicht denn ein rein
das ist auch etwas was sich dort nicht
findet und das ganz klar zu sagen
technisch übrigens auch sehr
herausfordernd aber deshalb
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt im
augenblick auf das was wir tun wollen
zur entlastung der bürger und bürgern
ich habe eben hier schon berichtet dass
ich glaube dass wir in der lage sein
werden das auch zu finanzieren was wir
erforderlich finden
was ist das
in dieser lage
das ist eine diskussion die geführt wird
im politischen raum und sie kennen die
entsprechenden ideen die bei der spd
diskutiert werden bei den grünen auch
aber gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir ja
als regierung uns auf die dinge
konzentrieren über die wir uns
sinnvollerweise zuallererst verständigen
müssen und dass das jetzt zuallererst
ansteht ist neben den entscheidungen die
wichtig sind für unsere energie
versorgungs sicherheit dass wir gut
durch diesen winter und das nächste jahr
kommen die frage was tun wir zur
entlastung der bürger und bürger über
das hinaus was wir schon gemacht haben
und ich wiederhole was ich gerade der
kollegen gesagt habe ich glaube das
werden wir finanzieren
wie ich eben auch schon gesagt habe ich
habe im bundestagswahlkampf im
wahlprogramm vertreten dass solche
gerechtigkeitsfragen adressiert hat
im ist frage frau dankbar
christine dankbar berliner zeitung
angesichts der zeit habe ich nur eine
frage herr bundeskanzler wann haben sie
das letzte mal mit johannes kahrs
gesprochen
jetzt will ich nicht die antwort geben
die einige hier fürchten
aber es ist schon ewig lange her sein
das heißt sie haben aktuell keinen
kontakt zu ihm nein
die nächste frage herr naja
ich
lade sie alle besuchen in der arabischen
welt
die nächste frage die ich noch habe
also die erste frage ich habe sie kurz
beantworten welche hier sagt noch mal
den ganzen satz jahren natürlich plane
ich eine reise und das wird gerade
sorgfältig ermuntert was die frage
betrifft der energielieferung aus den
verschiedenen arabischen ländern sind
wir dazu in mehreren gesprächen wir
haben ein
vorgehen das ja für deutschland bedeutet
dass wir
privatwirtschaft nicht akteure haben die
diese import vereinbarungen treffen
müssen und dass wir das als staat
politisch begleiten es gibt keine
staatliche das öl kohle
handelsgesellschaft in größenordnung die
das machen könnte wie das in manchen
anderen ländern der fall ist und darum
bleibt das immer ein etwas hybrides
projekt zwischenstaatlicher aktivität
und zur privatwirtschaftlichen
vereinbarung bei denen wir aber das kann
ich ihnen versichern so hinterher sind
dass wir uns jetzt natürlich mit größter
intensität anschauen wenn man alles
zusammenrechnet ist die energie
versorgungssicherheit deutschlands für
die nächsten jahre und jahrzehnte
gewährleistet und da bleiben
die nächste
unterstützung für
leider in polen wir sehen diese
unterstützung nicht
verbohrt hat über 100 panzer und
panzerhaubitzen
geschickt hat deutschland in dieser zeit
vor allem
sogenannte ringtausch polen bekommt
andere aus deutschland und was wir
anders werden
schönen dank für ihre fragen ich will
trotzdem dazu sagen deutschland ist im
augenblick unter den ländern die
fortschrittlichsten und auch für die
gegenwärtige militärische
auseinandersetzung essentiell ssten
waffen ich hatte mehrfach raketenwerfer
gibt es aus deutschland und aus den usa
und großbritannien
die sind sehr wirksam und helfende
ukraine gegenwärtig in dieser situation
der radpanzer gepaart der wichtig ist
damit die truppen unbehelligt von
angriffen aus der luft agieren können
und man auch bestimmte räume schützen
kann kommt aus deutschland
sehr kompliziertes hochmodernes
hocheffektives gerät wo wir die soldaten
soldaten der ukraine schuld haben wir
jetzt ein großteil der plaques panzer
bereits geliefert ist der rest kommt und
ganz kurzer zeit wir haben
den die panzerhaubitze 2000 geliefert
zusammen mit den niederlanden mit denen
wir auch militärisch in dieser frage
sowieso integriert zusammenarbeiten und
das ist doch eine sehr bedeutende menge
wenn ich zur richtigen koffer sind es 19
zusammen mit den niederlanden letzten
lieferung auch noch geliefert haben
werden und zusammen mit den waffen
anderer sind das hoch effiziente geräte
auch das wird übrigens aus der ukraine
berichtet sogar die intensiv silly
einsätzen in einer intensität die also
zeit da kann man richtig was mit
bewirken und das gilt dann auch für
vieles vieles andere was wir zur
verfügung gestellt haben darunter sind
auch sehr moderne geräte über die
teilweise die bundeswehr selber nicht
verfügt und die wir versuchen von der
industrie neu zu beschaffen dazu gehört
zum beispiel ihres t
möglichkeit die die luftabwehr an der
großen stadt will deshalb zum beispiel
gewährleisten kann das ist ein modernes
neues produkt aus der industrie wozu das
unternehmen zusammen mit uns den
eigentlich geplanten
empfänger dieser
dieses geräts überreden musste dass er
zurück steht was gelungen ist und wenn
wir weitere produktionen machen wollen
sind die ja auch nicht über nacht fertig
aber auf alle fälle müssen die entweder
zusätzlich produziert werden können von
der industrie oder andere müssen
zurückstehen gilt übrigens auch für das
dem nächste ausgelieferte radar cobra
was dazu beiträgt dass wir in der lage
sind die stille das dass die ukraine in
der lage sein wird russische artillerie
zu identifizieren und damit auch
entsprechend effizienter zu sein das
wird einen substanziellen unterschied
machen für die situation und das wir vor
einem großen umfang nicht nur munition
und minen
alle möglichen waffen geliefert haben
sondern auch panzerabwehrwaffen und
flugabwehrwaffen das soll nur gesagt
sein wenn man sich die liste der
deutschen die von anguckt und auch ihre
qualität dann wird man sehen dass es
hoch effizient und das ist auch genau
das was in der gegenwärtigen situation
benötigt wird darüber hinaus bemühen wir
uns zusammen mit anderen sicherzustellen
dass die in der ukraine genutzten waffen
viele waffen des früheren warschauer
vertrages
dass die auch genutzt werden können dass
das neue munition darüber gibt dass sie
operiert werden können und dass wir auch
weitere lieferungen von solchen geräten
zur verfügung stellen darüber sind wir
mit mehreren ländern in konkreten
gesprächen mit einigen haben wir sie
bereits finalisierte tschechien mit
anderen wollen wir das gerne machen und
sind auch kurz davor dass das jetzt
passiert
insofern wird das unmittelbare wirkung
haben weil dann geräte die dort bekannt
sind für die munition vorhanden es
dorthin geliefert werden können aus
diesen ländern wir ersetzen das mit
unseren dann modernisierten waffen
meistens aus industrie beständen die
dort zurück geliefert worden sind
modernisiert worden sendung eingesetzt
werden können auch für polen gilt die
bereitschaft dass wir das gerne machen
und vereinbarungen wie wir sie mit
tschechien gemacht haben mit der
slowakei anstreben mit griechenland
machen sind in polen auch möglich ich
glaube dass eine ernsthafte betrachtung
nur einen schluss zulässt dass eine
verständigung mit polen in gleicher
weise wie mit seinen nachbarländern
möglich ist
die denn gewünscht ist und das werde ich
gern hier nochmal am 9 also gerade wenn
man sich die sache von guckt geht er
eine oder andere sagt bin ich mir da
nicht so sicher aber ich wiederhole
wenn sich die wünsche so darstellen wie
sie sich darstellen andere länder als
nachbarn tons die sehr genau auf dieser
basis entweder kurz vor vertragsschluss
stehen oder in schon gemacht haben dann
wird das auch mit polen möglich sein und
wir sind dazu gerne bereit und zwar
schon sehr sehr lange
ich hatte hier auf der rechten seite
eine frage ja
sagen denn ich darf sie habe mehrmals
gesagt es darf kein diktat frieden geben
können sie uns sagen riechen sie sich
vor dass der westen europa oder
deutschland zu einem ende des krieges
beitragen könnte weil die teilweise ist
die zerstörung
enorm und und jetzt wird gekämpft um den
großen
kernkraftwerk europas was ein unfall
dort würde natürlich möglicherweise auch
andere länder teilweise in den krieg
ziehen wie sehen sie was könnte man
machen denn das ende des krieges zu
beschleunigen und die zweite frage eine
frage eine frage insofern gehe ich da
mal rein
ich stelle mir zunächst mal bin erstmal
in der frage ganz klar dass ein frieden
nur einer sein kann denn die ukraine für
sich selber richtig findet deshalb bin
ich mit all denen nicht einverstanden
die jetzt oder vielleicht in zukunft
anfangen sich sachen auszudenken die
dann die ukraine richtig finden soll das
ist aus meiner sicht falsch es kann nur
der ukrainische präsident die klinisch
regierung das ukrainische parlament und
das ukrainische volk sein das sagt das
ist eine lösung die wir richtig finden
und das ist nun wiederum offensichtlich
wenn man von diesem ansatz ausgeht dann
wird es niemals funktionieren dass das
ein diktat frieden ist der irgendwelchen
russischen vorstellungen feucht die
letztendlich darauf hinauslaufen dass
sie teilweise oder ganz irre eroberungs
ziele einfach durchsetzen können das ist
aus meiner sicht offensichtlich und
deshalb ist das eine große große
notwendigkeit dass wir dem quellen auch
weiter finanziell und militärisch mit
den waffen unterstützen wie wir das
bisher tun
und gleichzeitig müssen wir uns der
frage des wiederaufbaus widmen all der
infrastrukturen der gebäude der
einrichtungen die jetzt durch diesen
krieg betroffen sind das sind
dramatische zerstörung das wird
milliarden kosten und das wird die ganze
weltgemeinschaft den anspruch nehmen
dort vernünftige lösung zu entwickeln
wir hatten jetzt gerade erst die
konferenzen in der schweiz ich bemühe
mich mit der europäischen kommission
zusammen auch
das voranzutreiben
intellektuell die frage zu erörtern wie
man eigentlich das riesige programm
stemmen kann in einer welt insbesondere
nach dem krieg sich aus dieser situation
heraus zu befreien und die ukraine zu
unterstützen das wird eine große große
aufgabe die mit marshall plan glaube ich
nur geringfügig geschrieben ist das ist
größer
so wir sind leider mit der zeit weit
fortgeschritten und haben ihn sein limit
überschritten ich habe jetzt noch zeit
für zwei fragen sie bitte und dann
vorkoster
es ist nicht der echte
nikolaus doll von der welt der
bundeskanzler wenn ich den thema dessen
was jetzt hier gesagt haben grob
zusammenfassen
dann lautet die botschaft höchst
deutlich es wird alles gut wir tun was
und wir werden weiter was tun trotz
aller herausbringen und jetzt die frage
so formulierte mit sich mit jahren nein
antworten inwieweit sehen sie denn in
allen bereichen ton kriegsfolgen
energiesicherheit teuerung sich doch
dass das krisen managen sie wirklich
dass das krisen management und läuft
inwieweit sehen sie nicht auf die
notwendigkeit dass man den einen oder
anderen punkt noch besser machen könnte
bei ihrem krisenmanagement
die
herausforderung die mit dem ukraine
krieg mit dem weg russlands gegen die
ukraine verbunden sind die
herausforderung für preisentwicklung
wirtschaftsentwicklung
energieversorgungssicherheit sind immens
und deshalb beschäftigen wir uns
ernsthafte weise regelmäßig und intensiv
damit was wir als nächstes noch machen
müssen ein anderer ansatz wäre völlig
falsch ich bin froh dass wir sehr früh
angefangen haben dass wir sehr früh sehr
weitreichende entscheidung getroffen
haben aber wir werden gewissermaßen
nicht irgendwann mal die hände in den
schoß legen können sind wir müssen da
weitermachen und die lage beobachten und
die richtigen entscheidung treffen gilt
natürlich auch für die anderen
herausforderungen wie zb die von ihnen
angesprochene bekämpfung der coop 19
pandemie wir haben versprochen dass wir
die gesetzlichen rahmenbedingungen für
handlungsmöglichkeiten der länder
sicherstellen werden bevor die
gegenwärtigen auslaufen wir haben gesagt
das werden wir im august vorstellen dass
es jetzt passiert auch diskutiert worden
mit den chefs der 16 staatskanzleien der
länder mit dem gesundheitsministerium
genutzt und als ministerin und wir haben
diskutieren das auch mit anderen und
unser programm ist dass wir am anfang
des
wenn der bundestag im september zusammen
kommt diese gesetze gleich beschließen
so dass es einen unmittelbaren anschluss
für handlungsmöglichkeiten für den
ganzen winter gibt wenn die gesetze die
heute gelten am 23 september auslaufen
und das ist mit klappen insofern bin ich
ganz zufällig die natürlich führen wir
die diskussion jetzt mit den ländern
um jetzt ein gemeinsames projekt daraus
zu machen also da wird ja nicht
diskutiert um mitzuteilen dass wir
richtig finden sollen um das
gewissermaßen in
kooperation mit einander zu stande zu
bringen aber wenn man genau hinschaut
die von den wissenschaftlern
wissenschaftlern von den relevanten
politikern politikern in den letzten
wochen geforderten handlungsoptionen
sind substanziell verankert und stehen
dann zur verfügung welchen verlauf die
kurve 19 pandemie im herz nehmen wird
das kann niemand sicher vorhersagen wenn
es gut läuft muss man ja viele dieser
handlungsmöglichkeiten auf landesebene
nicht nutzen wenn es aber eng kommt
stehen sie dann zur verfügung
barbara kostolnik von der ag
angesichts der vielen krisen das
schließt ein bisschen so an und der
dramatischen krise lagen vermissen sie
angela merkel und wenn ja warum wenn
nein warum nicht
also
ich telefoniere gern mit ihr aber ich
bin jetzt auch gerne bundeskanzler
falls das die frage war
okay so dann sind wir durch das war
danke fürs kommen wir die
bundespressekonferenz trat ihre geduld
und ich bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit schönen dank für ihre
zeit